[Musique]
c'est encore ça arrive à nous faire
mincir maïté on peut relever à ferrières
rumeurs seigneur si c'est chaud votre
mari ou de voilà vous pouvez pas tout ça
c'est fini
mais maintenant la meilleure oui c'est
un gâteau au chocolat vous allez le voir
vous même attendait mais en fait je
crois que c'est un ami on peut rêver une
religion
[Applaudissements]
avoir un ténor le plaisir et le bonheur
de la manger alors je le mets voyez-vous
contre la joue il est chaud très chaud
très chaud très chaud on est là voyez je
commence déjà à voir de la grèce vers la
figure c'est ça qui est pas joli et que
deux il me tarde la tarte déguster je
commence à le prendre à lui sucer
derrière aux bonnes moeurs et trouville
déguster ce que je mange froid
[Applaudissements]
je suis grand je suis sûr de manger ça
devant vous mais mes vraies marges
je suis avez vous de tout coeur est avec
vous régalez vous avec moi en même temps
que chez hbo d'habitants nous assure ce
absolument minière ce royaume uni
capable mûri pour abriter d'une coop que
sera content parce que le truc comme ça
on le fait une fois deux fois mais par
trois avec un poulet avec une pintade
avec un canard est ce que vous voudrez
[Musique]